Overall, I think the media has to be much
tougher on those in power.
His network, as well as the others, it is
really a bully pulpit, and I mean they bully
people, not those in power.
Then the tough questions are, “Are you gonna
run for president?” or “When are you gonna
announce?” or “Who’s gonna be your vice
presidential running mate?”
All the speculative stuff.
But when it comes down to what they represent
and who they’re affecting, and not them
being asked these questions but people themselves,
breaking the sound barrier of the media, bringing
in the people who are the targets of these
policies.
That’s the really most egregious…
I would say, it’s who the media leaves out,
which is the majority of people.
They send the talk shows that are sponsored
by the weapon manufactures, by the food processors,
you know.
We’re in a global fuel crisis, oil companies
making more money than they’ve ever made
in their history.
They’re bringing us the Sunday talk shows
that set the agenda in this country.
The weapons manufacturers, the Boeings, the
Exxon Mobils, they’re the ones that are
defining the debate.
I’m not saying that they won’t ask questions
of them, but it’s a matter of you ask the
occasional tough question or you…
The continual drum beat, that’s what doesn’t
happen when you have a media brought to us
by the very corporations that profit off of
people’s pain.